en saône et loire deuxième débat de
l'émission reste même en partie au
creusot où nous sommes sur ce cette
esplanade de l'arc la scène nationale
qui nous accueillent aujourd'hui 3e
circonscription autun le creusot la
nature l'agriculture la viticulture avec
bien sûr l'industriel paul du creusot et
ben on va présenter tout le monde un
député sortant bonjour philippe baumel
bonjour élu en 2012 on vous arranger
pendant ce quinquennat on va en parler
dans les rangs des frondeurs pour la
république en marche rémy rebeyrotte
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le maire
d'autun une des deux villes principales
de cette circonscription pierre-étienne
graffard bonjour vous porter les
couleurs d'europe écologie les verts
vous êtes par ailleurs élu au creusot
cher l'indre bonjour bonjour lilian
melet élus au creusot vous aussi vous
vous présentez pour les républicains
avec l'investiture du parti que vous
avez finalement obtenu quentin bigeard
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le candidat du
front national dans cette élection et
pierre aceituno bonjour bon candidat
pour la france a soumises pour mieux
vous connaître et pour vous comprendre
vous proposons donc de vous présenter de
nous dire quelles sont vos motivations
va faire ça dans l'ordre dans lequel je
vous ai présenté en commençant par vous
philippe baumel écoutez moi je suis donc
député depuis cinq ans je souhaite
renouveler ce mandat tout simplement
pour continuer à défendre ce territoire
un territoire qui a bien bien besoin
d'être toujours et encore attendus à
paris sur des dossiers industriels ce
dossier sanitaire sur tout ce qu'il faut
en vérité pour développer un territoire
qui ressurgit progressivement dans un
contexte difficile
merci rémy rebeyrotte wii ou professeurs
d'économie
parce que c'est important j'ai toujours
souhaité ne pas être un professionnel de
la politique mais aussi de garder un
métier ça c'est quelque chose
d'important maire d'autun président du
grand autunois morvan est candidat pour
la république en marche c'est à dire
pour donner une majorité au président de
la république et faire en sorte que le
projet qu'il a présenté puisse
concrètement se mettent en oeuvre au
service du pays
merci rémy rebeyrotte puritaine graffard
vos motivations votre personne ce pas
flagrant en première vue mais je suis
nouveau en politique
mon engagement remonte en 2014 pour les
municipales du creusot comme vous voulez
trois ans en tant que élus pour
appréhender les problématiques du
territoire et le champ des possibles
dans les politiques menées sous les
couleurs d'europe écologie les verts
c'est une offre de service que je fais à
toutes celles et à tous ceux qui
souhaitent la prise en compte des enjeux
auxquels nous devons faire face la santé
l'énergie le travail le climat ça dans
des solutions novatrices et respectueuse
et de l'humain et de son environnement
merci charles l'arbre bonjour je suis
creusotin je me suis présenté à
l'élection municipale au creusot en 2014
où j'ai réuni 48 % des suffrages et j'ai
une activité indépendante dans le
domaine de la communication
alors depuis 18 mois je sillonne la
circonscription je me suis rendu dans
les 127 communes qui la composent et
parce que maintenant je crois que je
connais bien le territoire eh bien je
souhaite le défendre à paris parce que
nos territoires de petites villes et de
villages nos territoires ruraux en ont
besoin je souhaite le promouvoir le
valorise et puis aussi porter parce que
je crois que je n'incarne des pratiques
politiques nouvelles
merci quand un blizzard bonjour quentin
bigeard j'ai 22 ans je suis du creusot
je suis commercial depuis six ans
j'exerce en tant qu'auto entrepreneur
dans l'informatique
je me suis engagé mois politiquement à
mes seize en adhérant prénationale puis
j'ai milité jusqu'à maintenant dans
toute la saône-et-loire
je suis actuellement le responsable du
front national de saône-et-loire
jeunesse
j'ai beaucoup d'ambition pour le
territoire concernant la sécurité
l'emploi l'école de la république c'est
donc pour cela que j'ai décidé de me
lancer dans la bataille des législatives
pour porter des valeurs qui me sont
chères celles de marine le pen et pour
défendre la ruralité
merci pierre aceituno alors bonjour c
est pierre haas et uno j'ai 25 ans et je
suis venu
ici pour pouvoir défendre le programme
l'avenir en commun le problème de la
france est soumise
parce que je pense que c'est le seul qui
est à même de répondre aux enjeux
climatiques aux enjeux sociaux et aux
enjeux écologiques qui se présente à
nous aujourd'hui
alors on va faire un peu de politique
est politique nationale vous l'avez
compris on fait ça dans chaque émission
mais finalement le contexte nous
l'imposent un peu philippe baumel au
parti socialiste il ya une ligne benoît
hamon a une ligne bernard cazeneuve on
va dire c'est pas tout à fait la même
par rapport à au président de la
république vous vous situez où vous
dites quoi aux gens que vous rencontrez
dans cette campagne
écoutez je crois pas que cette campagne
servent à faire un congrès du parti
socialiste je pense que l'enjeu est tout
à fait différent l'essentiel aujourd'hui
c'est mais elle sert à dire où vous vous
situez quand même par rapport au
président absolument mais je pense qu'on
a à peu près repérer dans ses
concessions où je me situe je suis
socialiste et parfois il m'arrive aussi
de dire non un certain nombre de projets
je les fais pendant ce mandat je les
fais quand il s'est agi par exemple dire
non au cic eux de dire non à la loi
travail et d'être aussi en rupture sur
la déchéance de nationalité
tout ça ça éclaire peut être le chemin
pour le mandat qui vient c'est à dire
qu'il faudra être constructive mais il
faudra pas se perdre
il faudra savoir accepter un certain
nombre de réformes mais il faudra
toujours être en vigilance sur une
colonne vertébrale qui est à la fois
celles de la république et celles de la
gauche
pierre étienne graffard il y avait eu
accord
europe ecologie ps avant la
présidentielle maintenant vous êtes plus
côte à côte mais face à face par rapport
à ce que dit philippe baumel vous vous
situez où nous et je m'inscris dans la
cohérence politique qui a été la nôtre
pour les présidentielles avec la
plateforme jadot hamon nous n'avons pas
retrouvé les auditions pour prolonger
notre accord programme faute de temps
d'où notre autonomie sur cette élection
toujours par cohérence mais sans
rejoindre la majorité présidentielle
nous soutiendrons nicolas hulot pour
mettre en oeuvre la transition
écologique et la salle de solidarité que
porte sur 1000 son ministère
pas besoin d'être écologiste pour se
rendre compte de la rudesse de sa tâche
pour le reste nous serons vigilants
clairement dans une opposition
constructive
quant au libéralisme qu'on nous promet
de le permettra charles londres
premier ministre de droite vous allez
dire c'est la question que j'ai déjà
posé tout à l'heure a dit le pape voilà
mais c'est la même question qui se pose
pour vos électeurs potentiels
moi je crois que d'abord pour faire de
la politique aujourd'hui il faut de la
constance dans l'engagement la constance
des idées et qu'il ya eu des débauchages
individuels entre les deux entre les
deux tours de la présidence après la
part dont le deuxième tour de la
présidentielle et avant les législatives
cela regarde ce qu'ils ont accepté moi
je me pose
il n'y a pas dans le programme des
modèles macron des choses qui les
intéressent voilà au delà des qualités
justement je vais aller et venir
directement j'y viens pardonnez moi je
me pose dans un
une position qui est très clair je suis
dans un en opposition aux prises dans la
pluie mais dans un système d'opposition
constructive
c'est à dire que il ya un certain nombre
de mesures que je voterai par exemple
tout ce qui concerne la moralisation
pardon de la vie politique
même si sur certains points je pense
qu'il faut aller plus loin que ce qui
est que ce qui est proposé et puis il ya
des positions sur lesquels je m'oppose
par exemple la hausse de la fiscalité et
je le dis très clairement je voterai
contre la hausse de la csg à 1,7 pour
cent telle qu'elle est proposée par le
président de la république et qui
touchera durement le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités
donc je crois qu'il faut de la constance
de l'engagement et c'est ce que je
propose aux électeurs et la promotion du
territoire aussi et je vois que vous
voyez venir sur le terrain on va parler
de ce territoire quentin bigeard pas de
subtilités comme on peut les avoir à
droite pour vous opposition moi je serai
bien évidemment dans l'opposition face
au gouvernement macron je m'opposerai
également donc à la hausse de la csg a
voulu par monsieur macro 1 qui touchera
principalement les petites retraites
je trouve aussi important donc qu'il
faudra rétablir la demi part fiscale
supplémentaire pour les veufs et les
veuves la défiscalisation à la
majoration des heures supplémentaires
mais surtout expulser les fichiers s est
rangée et déchoir de leur nationalité
les binationaux convaincu de liens que
le djihadisme
c'est ce que je défendrai à paris pierre
aceituno
dans les sondages la france a soumises
baisse ces derniers jours le ps remonte
il se passe quoi il se passe qu'il ya un
une omerta médiatique sur le personnage
de jean luc mélenchon on attaque sa
personne au lieu de parler des idées
qu'on défend alors c'est est-ce que
c'est du fait de des polémiques qui soit
installée dernièrement ou est ce que
c'est ça vient du fait que jean luc
mélenchon a peut-être mal répondu ou mal
compris ce qui lui était reproché vous
l'expliqué sur le terrain ça aux gens
que vous rencontrez vous en parlez moi
ce que j'explique sur le terrain c'est
que de toute façon on vote pas pour une
personne là on est en train de décider
des gens qui vont gouverner le pays dans
les cinq prochaines années et donc de la
politique qui va être mise en place que
l'on soit d'accord avec les prises de
position de jean luc mélenchon et
notamment sur la sphère cazeneuve
qu'on soit d'accord avec lui qu'on
trouve que le termes qu'il a employés
abusif ou pas ça n'a pas d'importance ce
qui est important c'est quelle idée nous
défendons merci rémy rebeyrotte alors
candidat dans marche ça veut dire
soutien plein et massif au président de
la république en étant subtil marcheurs
de gauche ou marcheurs de droite
alors tout d'abord marcheurs et ça c'est
important
le débat au moins le mérite d'être clair
cinq opposants sur le plateau est
quelqu'un qui porte le projet du
président de la république avec la
volonté bien sûr de l'enrichir et
entendu les impositions raisonnée
constructive
ces propositions constructives moi je
demande à voir si vous voulez comme la
fronde je demande à voir aussi moi si
vous voulez je pense qu'effectivement
enrichir le projet c'est une chose
donnée au président la chance de pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre le programme sur lequel
il a été élu
moi je rencontre beaucoup d'électeurs
qui disent on n'a pas forcément voté
pour le président maquereau au moment de
la présidentielle mais maintenant il est
en place il réussit je crois vraiment un
sans faute depuis qu'il a été élu je
pense qu'il prend vraiment complètement
la dimension il incarne pleinement la
dimension de la fonction et beaucoup me
disent on va lui donner effectivement sa
chance la possibilité de pouvoir
rassembler pour réformer le pays parce
que nous avons besoin d'une majorité
d'idées et d'une majorité qui réforme le
pays il ya une voilà un petit clin
d'oeil avoue philippe baumel en disant
opposition constructive j'y crois pas
c'est comme la fronde
c'était pour vous la fronde peut-être
oui tout à fait mais mais c'est pas
grave moi je je suis plutôt fier d'avoir
été frondeurs parce que pour moi c'est
le témoignage d'une fidélité fidélité au
mandat qui m'avait été donnée fidélité à
mes électeurs qui ne m'avait jamais élu
pas plus moi que françois hollande
pourrait nécessiter essayer de mettre en
place par exemple la déchéance de
nationalité
donc j'ai été fidèle je serai fidèle je
ne suis ni en marche ni à la brasse
coulée
on essaie simplement d'être utile dans
un contexte qui est très difficile pour
notre pays
probablement que ce quinquennat est
probablement le dernier qui peut être
utile à la république et à la démocratie
dans ce pays parce que s'il venait à
échouer
on sait bien que le rendez vous suivant
c'est probablement le rend ces deux
rendez-vous avec le pire c'est-à-dire
avec les extrémistes qui incarne
monsieur bizarre mais je préviens je
pense qu'il faut donc du coup être
constructive dans ce mandat est
probablement encore une fois essayé de
tenir une ligne
je ne sais pas si elle est journaux ciel
et rouge je préfèrerais qu'elles soient
rouges et ne pas se perdre dans des
propositions qui risque d'être très néo
libéral simon ce qu'il faut surtout de
la cohérence
surtout de la cohérence est vrai qu'il
faut être cohérent et par exemple eh oui
cela le garder impliqué en politique de
non échange et de responsabiliser et de
la capacité d'être justement sont
errants et de faire avancer changer
changer nouvelle
j'ai devant littéralement dépend
littéralement la réussite de ce
quinquennat je le crois fondamentalement
je ne suis plus dans un parti politique
depuis 2012 depuis le 9 novembre
écrivait encore aux tensions demande
hysteria non non non non monsieur baumel
je ne suis plus je ne suis plus au parti
socialiste depuis 2012 et notamment
j'ai toujours été en conflit avec la
fédération telle qu'elle était ici en
saône et loire
parce que si vous voulez la manière de
faire de la politique il était tout le
temps en étant en permanence en
permanence dans des logiques
d'affrontement et de clivages je crois
que c'est justement ce dont aujourd'hui
les français ne veulent pas les gens
profitent je vous coupe c'est le moment
d'ouvrir un chapitre suivant et bien sûr
vous allez tous vous exprimer encore
plus sur le chapitre suivant on va
accueillir réaccueillir alors je sais
pas si le moribond benoit montaggioni
mon confrère du journal de saône et
loire c'est notre partenaire pour cette
émission d'ailleurs qui ad'ailleurs
foncia juste là bas à benoît et on
s'était dit benoît que dans cette
circonscription on est au creusot bien
sûr il ya le poids de l'industrie et ya
le poids de l'industrie en particulier
nucléaire qui peut être dans le
programme de ces législatives
on est juste à côté de la forge d'areva
qui est vraiment où tout près on va
parler de la place de l'industrie et
donc de celle du nucléaire et j'ai envie
de me diriger vers le candidat
écologiste en premier est-ce que c'est
compliqué de faire campagne quand on est
un candidat écolo et bien sûr les terres
de l'industrie et un peu sur les terres
du nucléaire aussi
oui bien sûr que c'est bien sûr que
c'est compliqué et bien sûr que ça
demande une des des explications et de
la pédagogie n'est peut-être plus du
fait qu' on est sur un site qui a marqué
par le nucléaire pour le nucléaire la
question est malheureusement très simple
parce que l'effet travail pour nous
je veux dire je dis malheureusement
parce que rien n'est anticipée pas de
stratégie énergétique au niveau national
digne de ce nom pas de préparations
industrielles pour la reconversion
donc c'est compliqué tout à fait mais au
contraire on assiste malheureusement
encore une fois un autre traitement
dogmatique entre autres sur les et opère
bon je rappelle que le prc 3 milliards
annoncés aujourd'hui alors qu'on n'a
encore pas démarré ces 10 milliards 5 c
donne juste une idée de cette dérive de
la filière nucléaire
je vous coupe pour pas qu'on parte trop
dans l'est dans les temps qu'ils
arrêtaient graffard sinon après je
pourrai plus vous donnez de temps de
parole on va continuer avec rémy
rebeyrotte par exemple le ministre de
l'environnement que s'est choisi
emmanuel macron et leur phillips et
monsieur hulot
quand on est candidat ici sur la
circonscription du creusot est ce qu'on
dit aux électeurs
moi ma vision du nucléaire c'est la même
que celle de monsieur hulot moi je crois
que l'objectif fixé par le président de
la république qui est d'augmenter en
quelque sorte la diversité du mix
énergétique et de ramener la part du
nucléaire à 50% en 2025 c'est un
objectif déjà compte tenu de notre
situation d'aujourd'hui d'un objectif
ambitieux j'allais même dire audacieux
donc ça ne veut pas dire qu'on tourne la
page du nucléaire ça veut dire que on en
diminue effectivement la part on
continue à porter les recherche et
l'innovation dans le secteur du
nucléaire
et c'est pas effectivement en terre
creusotine que l'on va découvrir ce que
on peut encore améliorer comment on peut
innover comment on peut chercher encore
davantage la recherche la formation dans
le secteur du nucléaire ça parle en
terre creusotine philippe baumel vous
avez soutenu pendant l'élection
présidentielle benoît hamon candidat du
parti socialiste qui est venu dans le
coin qui est venu visiter l'entreprise
qui fabrique des mâts d'éoliennes on
sait par exemple le maire du creusot lui
n'a pas tout à fait la même ligne sur la
question du nucléaire que l'ex candidat
hamon alors vous sur cette question vous
êtes plutôt amont plutôt marty je pense
qu'il faut évidemment considérer
l'existant on a un point de départ qui
est celui d'une industrie nucléaire une
énergie du pjak est très importante pour
la consommation des français et de
l'industrie française et où il faut
tenir un objectif qui est celui de la
conversion vers des énergies
renouvelables on a aussi une belle
entreprise vous avez cité c hall qui
fabrique des mâts d'éoliennes ici c'est
toute cette logique là qu'il faut savoir
installer avec un véritable programme
européen une communauté européenne des
énergies renouvelables c'est cela vers
lequel il va falloir tendre et ça il va
falloir le défendre dans le quinquennat
qui vient moi je suis de suite g13 très
envie de défendre cette logique là parce
que derrière tout cela il ya une
capacité de créer beaucoup d'emplois
notamment sur un bassin des industriels
comme celui là on en est un énorme
déficit et sur l'éolien et sur le
solaire on sait que tout cela on ne
pourra le faire que s'il ya une démarche
véritablement à plusieurs pays
un petit peu comme les allemands
d'ailleurs l'ont fait ces dernières
années bien il faut savoir le faire
aussi ici en france pierre aceituno
finalement c'est ça qui sait ce sujet le
nucléaire qui fait que aujourd'hui avec
le parti communiste vous n'êtes pas
d'accord et vous êtes candidat chacun de
votre côté vous n'avez pas la même
vision à la france insoumise de de ce
que doit être l'avenir de l'énergie
française pour répondre brièvement ya
pas que ce sujet là qui fait qu'on n'est
pas en accord avec le parti communiste
et notamment on ne partage pas la vision
électoraliste qui l'ont qui vient du
fait qu'il ya une certaine manière de
financer la vie politique aujourd'hui et
ils ont ils ont leur ligne ils ont leur
choix et
il s'est hissé dans leurs droits sur la
question du nucléaire
il ya quelque chose des choses qu'on
n'évoque pas c'est que il ya des des
choix stratégiques qui ont été faits
notamment je parle pour areva ici qui
sont non seulement dont jeu dangereux
mais qui en plus nous coûte très cher le
fait par exemple d'avoir décidé de
mettre en place des plans d'économies
mais pas des plans de sûreté notamment
le fait que à creusot forge ont fait des
vies roll avant pour faire des virées
l'ont commandé 80 tonnes de métal chez
industeel et maintenant on en commande
plus que 60 et 100 et 80 tonnes on
enlève 40 pour usiner la pièce
eh bien on se retrouve avec les
problèmes qui a eu récemment nés
notamment la qualité du matériel à la
sortie et les problèmes de taux de
carbone dans les pièces notamment les
tests de lepers 3 et après c'est facile
de venir derrière accusé les salariés
alors que n'ont fait que leur travail
il ya un problème de choix stratégique
qui a été fait il ya un problème
d'investissement qui auraient dû être
faits notamment ont fait sous traiter
des pièces au japon léger à l'est on
achète les fonds de cuve au japonais
alors qu'on pourrait si on installait
les machines pour le faire au creusot
on pourrait les fabriquer ici et il ya
une absence de vision stratégique de
vision de long terme
nous on pense que c'est la planification
écologique qui pourra permettre de
ramener cette dame née cette ville verse
merci pierre à ses toiles est-ce qu'on
peut juste juste on va dire le tour des
autres l'érythème grata parce que ils
ont ils ont pas parlé du tout sur ce
sujet et je vais adresser à charles
londres pour les républicains
on vient d'évoquer les problèmes qu'a
connus la forge du creusot est ce que
pour vous l'avenir de l'industrie de ce
bassin d'emploi il passe forcément par
le nucléaire
d'abord en tant que total va rappeler
qu'il n'ya pas que le nucléaire comme
industrie au creusot nous avons ici des
fleurons il ya areva et alstom il y à
industeel il y à safran et là c'est avec
la snecma juste en dessous alors je
donc le l'industrie creusotine ce n'est
pas uniquement le nucléaire néanmoins il
faut que nous ayons un état que son état
stratège en la matière qui imagine la
façon dont nous allons planifier les
énergies de demain et qui a à la fois
assurer l'indépendance énergétique de la
france
et imagine la façon dont nous réussirons
à bien vivre avec les énergies nouvelles
donc l'avenir 7 avec areva qu'il faudra
le construire avec la filière nucléaire
bien évidemment eh bien nous aurons je
l'espère la possibilité d'avoir une
multiplicité de ressources et de
capacité à créer de l'énergie
mais c'est avec ceux qui travaillent
aujourd'hui dans ces domaines là qu'il
faut imaginer l'avenir
et puis j'ajouterai que les difficultés
qu'ont qu'a rencontré ce groupe à cause
de choix stratégiques
enfin d'absence de soi stratégique
plutôt ces dernières années bien ça pèse
d'abord sur les salariés et que je peux
vous dire qu'il ya des salariés ici au
creusot qui sont des gens qui font un
travail d'exception et qu'il faut aussi
leur assurer une forme de sécurité
merci charles cantin bigeard pour le
front national vous allez peut-être
pouvoir m'éclairer marine le pen a eu
différentes interventions sur le
nucléaire ces dernières années on a du
mal à comprendre si finalement le front
national est un parti qui est pro
nucléaire ou pas alors sur ce sujet là
moi je pense je toute façon je ne ferai
pas ma priorité
sur la circonscription j'ai d'autres
priorités c'est pourquoi je n'en
parlerai pas n'avait pas d'avis sur ce
que doit être l'avenir énergétique non
mais moi je ne m'oppose pas du tout
à l'énergie nucléaire loin de là
d'accord alors quelles priorités pour
vous il ya sur cette circonscription est
bien donc la sécurité d'emploi et puis
la scolarité
c'est à dire ça va être un petit peu
court quand vous donne le même temps de
parole que les autres trois mots donc
pour la sécurité je trouve qu'il est
important de restaurer les effectifs de
police et de gendarmerie renforcer
l'arsenal judiciaire et créer d'urgence
des places de prison supplémentaires
pour permettre d' application stricte
des peines concernant l'emploi donc un
bon maintenant le secteur industriel la
france a perdu quand même trois millions
d'emplois en 30 ans et la ce et en saône
et loire le chômage continue de
progresser
est ce que le creusot est un modèle de
ce point de vue le rapport
je sais pas vous parler d'industrie
d'emploi vous parler de perte d'emploi
est ce que le creusot lui c'est un
modèle par rapport à ça on sait que le
creusot l'industrie s'y portent bien oui
l'industrie s'y portent bien voilà non
mais là je parlais au niveau national
donc après donc concernant la scolarité
je pense qu'il faut notamment miser sur
les matières essentielles comme
l'apprentissage du français
un tout petit mot vous voulez y répondre
mais alors en train de secondes puis
arrêté mme graf
non c'était juste pour compléter sur
creusot faut je pense que oui bon c'est
une question ou local je m'en excuse
mais mes creusot forge est en train de
payer le prix fort d'une façon très
injuste d'une gouvernance calamiteuse
pour pas dire plus de la période
lauvergeon et avant de la période
bolloré je veux dire c'est une des
particularités et dieu sait si le
nucléaire a des particularités spéciale
de la filière industrielle des clercs
qui qui s'arrogent de tous les droits et
ne respectent aucune des règles
oui ce soit dans la transparence et
viendra faire un tout petit mot
phénomène avant qu'on passe aux
conclusions oui je crois qu'il faut
avoir sur ces questions las de ces
questions industrielles majeures un état
véritablement stratège qui définit ce
des caps mais qui a au moins donné aussi
s'est investi financièrement je rappelle
quand même que la recapitalisation
d'areva pour éviter que areva ne
disparaisse complètement c'est quand
même l'ancien gouvernement qu'il
apportait vous acquiescez sur les
stratèges wii est un stratège et en même
temps ne pas effectivement se limiter au
nucléaire il y a il doit y avoir une
logique devrait véritablement de montée
en puissance de l'ensemble des énergies
notamment des énergies renouvelables
mais en même temps le nucléaire est
toujours
duy une énergie centrale majeur et il
faut qu effectivement nous puissions
continuer à investir pour encore
améliorer les process
on arrive à la fin de ce débat comme
prévu on passe aux conclusions 30
secondes chacun dans un ordre qui a été
tiré au sort préalablement avant
l'émission
merci de respecter la règle pendant que
vous parlez d'ailleurs les
téléspectateurs voient les 30 secondes
s'écoulaient en bas de l'écran et on
commence donc ses conclusions par vous
pierre etienne grâce à merci dimanche
prochain je sollicite votre confiance
pour mettre en oeuvre les engagements
qu'on a pris pour la coque 21 et pour
l'application de la loi de transition
écologique réussir cette mutation s'est
donné des solutions à de nombreux
problèmes que nous connaissons et en
particulier le chômage sur la troisième
circonscription
nous avons les moyens de participer
activement à cette mutation ne laissons
pas passer cette opportunité
ces cinq ans à venir doivent être utiles
à chacun de vous je souhaite y
participer dans un travail parlementaire
assidus en évitant vigilant constructif
pour le bien être et le bien vivre de
notre territoire je vais l'on pense et
je leur en paix je vous coupe la rétine
graffin on avait des 30 secondes quand
un blizzard alors moi député de la
troisième circonscription de la saône et
loire avec mon suppléant christian
dennis je m'engagerai à être proche et à
l'écouté de mes concitoyens lors du
deuxième tour d'élection présidentielle
la voix du peuple s'est fait entendre
plus forte que jamais il s'agit
désormais de l'affairé zone et au sein
de l'assemblée nationale
si vous m'élisez je n'aurais qu'une
seule boussole pour guidé mon action
défendre la france est protégé les
français
je défendrai les valeurs patriotiques et
républicaine celle de marine le pen à
l'assemblée nationale merci quentin
bigeard pierre à 7 ou nosta vous de
conclure alors ce que je voudrais dire
aux français c'est d'abord ne donnait
pas de majorité à monsieur emmanuel
macron parce que il ya le code du
travail parce que il ya des urgences qui
ne seront pas résolus avec avec ce
monsieur et les gens qui le suivent
je m'engage mois à être un député
révocable c'est-à-dire un député qui
défend l'avenir en commun et qui
respecte le mandat pour lequel il a été
élu
vous l'entendez on est en public ici je
vous le rappelle sur le sur l'esplanade
de l'arc du creusot quatrième à conclure
si vous rémy rebeyrotte d'abord
solidarité avec les familles en deuil et
à l'ombre et condamnation absolue et
ferme d' acte de cette nature et en même
temps volonté de construire avec
l'europe une sécurité encore plus forte
en lien entre tous avec marine mangione
qui elle est originaire de givry et qui
habite chagny nous sommes les candidats
de la république en marche
ceux qui vous l'ont justement donner
véritablement la possibilité au
président de la république de mettre en
oeuvre les mesures pour lequel il a été
élu j'ai tendance à penser que l'
inverse pourrait nous ramener à des
incertitudes importantes et peut-être à
la chienlit
merci rémy rebeyrotte philippe baumel
vous écoutez moi je voudrais être un
député utile utile à cette
circonscription sur un certain nombre de
dossiers locaux qui ont été évoqués
pendant cette émission sur les questions
industrielles sur les questions des
hôpitaux sur les questions de
l'éducation nationale évidemment et puis
être utile aussi pour reconstruire ce
pays mettre en place une et assurer le
devenir de notre république à laquelle
nous sommes très attachés
tout ça c'est très important ça peut
nous protéger nous projeter dans un 21e
siècle de façon ou totalement positive
ou totalement catastrophique donc ce
quinquennat un enjeu majeur
encore faut-il avoir pour le porter une
majorité utile et des députés qui soit
en capacité de porter un certain nombre
de valeurs pas uniquement de ceux qui se
mettent dans l'air du temps pour finir
par avoir un avenir de feuilles mortes
merci philippe baumel et charles l'ombre
c'est à vous donner une majorité utile
s'il vous plaît à ne réplique pas aux
conclusions charles d'un assist
finalement au congrès du parti
socialiste j'en suis ravi
moi je veux j'ai été un candidat de
proximité et de terrain et je serai un
député de terrain parce que je pense que
nos territoires ruraux nos territoires
de petites villes et de villages il faut
les défendre à l'assemblée nationale et
je le ferai je serai aussi un député
avec des idées claires qui défendra les
valeurs de liberté de justice sociale
qui valorisera le travail et enfin jeu
suis un député qui je crois que je
serais un député en tout cas qui je
crois incarne le renouvellement des
pratiques et je crois que c'est plus que
jamais nécessaire aujourd'hui
et donc je l'incarnerait pour la 3e
circonscription parce que nous sommes
sur une circonscription qui a un
potentiel et des atouts absolument
extraordinaire merci charles léandre
merci à tous les 6/7 terminé pour ce
débat vous l'entendez décidément c'était
vraiment en public on ne nous a pas
menti
signalons 600 candidats sur cette
troisième circonscription de
saône-et-loire serge desbrosses pour le
parti communiste roland essayan france
robert pour des élèves julie cote pour
elo muriel berthelier sylvain garcia
pour résistants florence pandraud pour
l'upm remercie beaucoup moins merci à
vous d'être venus participer à cette
émission et on se retrouve